دي من تاريخي للهداف التاريخي للكره
كريستيانو رونالدو بعد انتقاله رسميا
لنادي النصر السعودي تقديم رونالدو عاده
يكون ضخما الامر لم يتغير كذلك في مرسول
بارك لملائمه تاريخه الكبير في ذلك الملعب
الواقع في الرياض حضر قرابه 25,000 مشجع
لحضور تقديم النجم البرتغالي الحائز على
خمس كرات ذهبيه افضل لاعب في العالم
رونالدو وخلال مؤتمر تقديمه اكد انه فضل
عرض نادي النصر على عروض الاوروبيات مشيرا
الى انه جاء للسعوديه من اجل كسر الارقام
القياسيه وما اكثر التي حطمها والمشاركه
في ثقافه النادي والبلد
توماتيكو
الحرب
نعم صهيب بالفعل كانت تريلا غير عاديه
لعشاق النصر وعشاق كريستيانو على وجه
التحديد هنا في ملعب باسول بارك عندما تم
تقديم هذا اللاعب الاسطوري للمره الاولى
بشعار نادي سعودي نادي النصر وفي ملعب
مرسول مبارك الذي تزيل بشكل خاص
لكريستيانو رونالدو واستقباله وتقديمه
بشكل غير مسبوق سواء على مستوى السعوديه
او حتى على مستوى الشرق الاوسط او مستوى
اسيا وحتى على مستويات حتى قارات اخرى لم
يتم تقديم لاعب بهذه الطريقه سوا في
اوروبا يتم محاكاه هذا التقديم بما تم في
عام 2009 عندما قدم كريستيانو رونالدو في
السنتياجو برنابيو عندما انتقل الى ريال
مدريد وقدم
مبهرا جدا الحقيقه ولكن حدثنا عن المزيد
من التفاصيل في الكواليس عبد المحسن هل
هناك تفاصيل اخرى تبينت حول العقد بين
كريستيانو همم رونالدو النصر كذلك شاهدناه
كذلك مع
زملائه الجدد في فريق نادي النصر يبدو ان
العلاقه همم ستكون وديه بين زملائه في
النادي السعودي ما الذي تبين كذلك من
تفاصيل ربما همم فيما يتعلق بعلاقه
كريستيانو رونالدو مع النادي الجديد
بالفعل صهيب كان هنالك حديث كبير بان
كريستيانو قادم
لمشاركات ربما الشرفيه ولكن كريستيانو اا
ما قدمه ليوم سواء كان من همم تصاريح او
حتى تصرفات من خلال لقائه مع ال همم
اللاعبين واجتماعهم مع رئيس النادي وهذا
ما تم بعد المؤتمر الصحفي كان هنالك حديث
من قبل لاعبين النصر وكريستيانو تحديدا عن
انه لم يخدم الى
ليحصد المزيد من البطولات مع نادي النصر
وهو همم صرح به ما لاعبين النصر في همم
داخل غرفه الملابس قبل ان يظهر بشكل مباشر
للجمهور بعد ذلك تحدث للجمهور عن الكثير
من امنياته عن ايضا همم امنياته بان يحطم
الارقام همم بعد ان حطمها في اوروبا يقول
بانه يريد ان يحطم بالارقام في اسيا
فبالتالي هنالك حديث كبير من قبل
كريستيانو رونالدو بانه لم يقدم ولم تنتهي
مسيرتي هذا ما تحدث عن لم يقدم المشاركه
الشرافيه ولم ينت- تنتهي مسيرته بعد رد
على تصريحات همم الصحافه العالميه قال
بانه قادم للمشاركه بالفوز بالالقاب وهمم
قابل ذلك جمهور النصر بتحيه كبيره جدا
كريستيانو صهيب لم يكن يستطيع التحدث في
بعض الاجزاء التي تواجد في الملعب
نظرانيه هتافات كبيره جدا
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد المحسن مباشره من
الرياض
بعد هذا لاعب دولي لاعب مكسب للكره
السعوديه والعربي الاسيويه ونقل للكره
السعوديه في ثلاث دقائق الى العالميه
واصبح النادي الاعظم في العالم بحكم وجود
اللاعب فيه نادي النصر بالنسبه للصفقه
رونالدو انا شايف ان هي سبيري سمارت موف
من سوائل المملكه او نادي النصر وانا فاهم
ان هي برده صفقه تسويقيه ل 20 30 ان شاء
الله المملكه تقدر تعمل
تنظم كاس العالم
و رونالدو ما شاء الله عليه و الله يعرف
يلعب عالمي
هذا هذا اللي نقدر نقوله عن صفقه كبيره
مثل صفقه رونالدو مع النصر
وهذه صفقه جديده وان شاء الله يعني تتكرر
وتصير يعني صفقات عاليه اسطوريه احسن منها
وقال اذا على التقديم الاسطوري اليوم في
الرياض معلقا انا عالمي هذا هو هذه اول
صوره لكريستيانو رونالدو او اول بوست له
على حسابه على انستغرام الذي 528
مليون متابع طبعا بعد هذا الاستقبال
الاسطوري في منصور بارك اليوم في الرياض
بعد انضمامه رسميه لنادي النصر السعودي
انتقال كريستيانو ولي النصر نتائجه ليست
رياضيه فقط بل تجاريه وتسويقيه على صعد
كثيره اولها التاثير على البث صحيفه
الرياضيه السعوديه كشفت ان هناك قنوات
تلفزيون عالميه تسعى لبث مباريات النصر
السعودي خلال الفتره المقبله من اجل
رونالدو ثانيا التاثير على مبيعات القمصان
وهنا وضع رونالدو متجر النصر في ورطه
لكنها ورطه قميص النجم البرتغالي نافذه
خلال ساعات من طرحها الكل يتهافت عليه حتى
خارج السعوديه الطلبات من خارج السعوديه
عاليه جدا بحسب مراسل العربيه
الامر الثاني هو مواقع التواصل انتقال
رونالدو الى النصر شكل نقله نوعيه كبيره
بالنسبه للنادي السعودي على مستوى وسائل
التواصل فصفحه النادي السعوديه على
انستغرام حققت نقله ضخمه بزياده عدد
المتابعين بالالاف عدد متابعي صفحه النادي
تضاعف ويتضاعف مع مرور الوقت الان بدا
يتجاوز 8 ملايين ونصف المليون متابع علما
ان عدد المتابعين قبل الاعلان عن الصفحه
كان بالكاد يفوق 800,000 متابع
هذه زياده ضخمه جعلت النبي السعوديه تجاوز
حتى انديه عالميه في عدد المتابعين على
انستغرام فعدد متابعين مصر متى يتفوق على
متابعي انديه مثل روما الايطالي الذي يملك
حوالي 5 ملايين متابع كما ان النصر بات
يتجاوز ايضا انديه ذات شعبيه كبيره في
امريكا اللاتينيه مثل البالميراتسا
البرازيليه الذي لديه حوالي اربعه ملايين
متابعه لائحه الانديه التي تجاوزها مصر
تضم ايضا فرقا متالقه في الوقت الراهن مثل
نابولي المتصدر متصدر الدوري الايطالي
الذي لديه نحو ثلاثه ملايين متابع ومن بين
الانديه التي تتجاوزها العالمي ايضا نجد
مارسيليا الفرنسيه واستعمل الانجليزيه
باير ليفربول
ثلاثه ملايين